hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in chapter six of his treatise on truth
anselm is going to ask his student all
right we've looked at
truth in signification truth in thought
truth in the will truth in action
have we run the gamut of types of truth
other than the supreme truth
and the student says oh no there's
there's another very important kind of
truth also falsity
in the
senses of the the body you know very
often our senses are telling us things
that are true right so they're telling
us things when we see or hear or smell
but they also deceive us and you know
the examples that they run through here
are time worn by by this era you know
they're part of the literature on the
ways in which the senses deceive us but
let's let's take a look at them anyway
so there's colored glass you can look
through a piece of glass that's red and
you think that the things on the other
side are actually red or green or
whatever i mean you might think today
about like when a band is on stage or
you're seeing a
production on stage and there's there's
lamps that are projecting blue or red or
whatever
through the filters okay so that's one
important aspect then he talks about a
sculpted dragon and little kid seeing
the dragon with his mouth open and being
terrified of it whereas adults are like
uh that's just a statue so the kid's
senses deceive him the adult senses do
not deceive the adults he also talks
about
mixing up people like looking at a human
being and being like oh that's my friend
george and then they turn around and
then you're like well that's not even
george at all right or hearing a voice
in the dark or hearing something that
sounds like a human voice in the dark
but isn't and we might think here
about the difference between the sounds
of cats meowing and babies crying and
then we have
mirrors we look at our own face in the
mirror and if you were really you know
deceived you could think that's you in
the mirror or anything else right that's
a visual effect and then there's this
the famous stick in the water you put
the stick in the water and it looks bent
right these are almost all visual except
for a few
oral or sound examples but we could
think about
tastes and smells and touches and all
sorts of things like that that are
associated with the bodily senses and
the question that they're dealing with
here is well where is the truth
or the falsity what's what's telling the
truth or what's lying to us do our
senses
lie to us you know if we want to
paraphrase it who are you going to
believe your own lion eyes right
well according to anselm
the senses don't lie to us at all they
tell us a certain kind of truth right
it's not the exterior sense where the
problem arises
it's in what he calls opinion or
judgment opinio right making some sort
of assumption or claim
deciding that things are the case or
it's in our interior sense and here he
seems to be appealing to something like
what the ancients and medievals called
the common sense that puts things
together into
an actual object you know puts all the
sense perceptions together
and you know anselm isn't super worried
about you know how do we differentiate
these between each other the the key
thing here is that it's not the senses
or the sense apparatus itself that is
telling us lies about the exterior world
it's our own
judgments
our own what we do with those
perceptions how we put them together
that is deceiving us about what the case
actually is so if we see the stick go
into the water
and we think oh wow it is indeed bent
it's not our eyes that are deceiving us
it's not the sense impressions it's our
own judgment about that i suppose you
could say it's the interior senses
perception of the stick and the water
together right
and likewise for any of these other
things if i see a person and i'm like oh
that is uh my my wife and you know i go
and i tap somebody on the shoulder and
she turns around she's like who the hell
are you
okay obviously it wasn't my eyes that
deceived me it was my own judgment about
what my eyes are telling me
so the truth or falsity is in the
opinion or judgment or in the interior
senses and anselm goes on
he does provide a very interesting
discussion there about you know one
specific instance the
colored glass and how we're not supposed
to blame the eyes for that so the
exterior senses what do they do they
just report
or provide us with
what it is that they
themselves
take in according to their own you know
workings what what it is that they
register what it is that they
perceive and what are they doing they're
reporting it to the human being to the
interior sense first which is then
conveying that and saying this is the
way things are and then our minds say oh
okay cool that's that's the way things
actually are
and we could you know easily be deceived
in a number of different ways
as a matter of fact if anselm were here
today he would say you're routinely
deceived
through the use of audio-visual
technology right you listen to
a band you know for example motorhead
and you're listening to overkill
you know the the song that has uh three
endings to it it's one of the best metal
songs in history and you're
lemmy singing
fast eddie clark playing the guitar
lemmy playing the bass guitar
phil taylor you know hammering away on
the drums all those guys are dead
they don't exist anymore
are your senses deceiving you
your senses aren't deceiving you it's
your mind that's deceiving you in a
fairly routine way because we live in
this this interesting uh domain of media
products right so anselm would say that
that is all
equally talked equally understandable
in terms of this exterior senses and
interior senses and judgments right the
exterior senses
however it is that they come to do what
it is you know through nature
the way that they're set up or through
something else acting upon them
they they do what they ought to do
anselm calls that quote debent they are
doing what is their proper function what
they were made to do
and they actually do or enact
rectitude
rightness
and truth
this is very interesting because anselm
is not a person who is saying that well
the senses just report data and the data
itself is neither true nor false
he's actually saying no there's a truth
in the senses
and this interestingly is a truth that
is contained
under the rectitude of action which he
has just talked about in the previous
chapter
these senses act they do their proper
actions and in doing so
they are in fact
producing truth now the truth that
they're producing could be something
that isn't really the case you're
looking through the colored glass and
the person on the other side isn't
really green
right
but the senses think that they are
the senses themselves are not being
deceived they're just merely registering
what's there it's when it gets to the
opinion or judgment that we have the
issue and so
the fault or the falsity here as anselm
says is to be imputed in putandi
to the soul's judgment you diccio anime
so now we've actually got three
different terms that are being connected
together opinio which we can translate
as opinion or judgment uh census
interiors right the interior sense and
eudiccio
clearly stressing that there's an aspect
of our own
making a judgment here that is what gets
us in trouble and
generates falsity when we say things are
as the senses depict them
to us and we say so in a uncritical or
undeveloped or immature way the sculpted
dragon is an example he says of
immaturity that's why children get
afraid of the sculpted dragon
and
adults who know that it's not a real
dragon don't get afraid of it right and
we could think of many other examples
like that so this is uh truth in the
senses there is indeed truth in the
senses for ansem and then there can be
truth or falsity in what it is that
we're doing with what the senses report
to us either with the interior sense or
opinion or judgment or the soul's
faculty of judgment itself
you